SPEAKER 1: This
week, we're talking
about computing inside a
container, around the globe,
and across the stars.
Welcome to "This Week in
Cloud," where we serve you
the lowest-latency news.
If you're already building
an app with containers,
you know there's usually more
than just your code running.
Google Cloud's
Kubernetes apps gives you
a simple integrated way
to incorporate open source
and commercial offerings
into your environment.
This means that you can
deploy your app faster,
thanks to pre-built
deployment templates, default
configurations, and support
for popular packaging
formats like Helm charts.
Build your container once
and deploy your full app
anywhere with Kubernetes apps.
Our Google Cloud Osaka
Region is now live and ready
for business.
It's our second in Japan,
seventh in Asia-Pacific,
and 20th region overall.
And the benefits aren't
limited to just Osaka.
A second region in Japan
means lower latency and higher
availability for
existing users in Tokyo.
Read more about how this
is helping businesses
and see which regions we've
got coming up next on the blog.
BigQuery is great for
analyzing big data,
and it's hard to find bigger
data than astronomy data sets.
BigQuery's GIS tools aren't
just limited to Earth,
as you can read
about in the blog
post from Dr. Ross Thomson,
Google Cloud's solution
architect.
Ross talks about how
these astronomy data sets
can be analyzed, and how
BigQuery's built-in tools
helped make it possible
to query the stars.
This week is KubeCon.
And if you're there, come
check out all the Googlers
talking about Kubernetes.
If you couldn't make
it, don't worry,
because we'll have lots of
video content and write-ups
after the event.
You can also stay informed
with the Kubernetes
podcast, a weekly chat
about all things Kubernetes.
Last week they talked
about what Anthos
can do for your operations
teams, so make sure to tune in.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.